janet
janet what's that
what's that
what's this
her memory's still being rebooted
because oh you know someone murdered her
janet could you please locate the file
for an eleanor shellstrop born in
1982 phoenix arizona usa sure
anything else
no janet this is actually a cactus
this might take a while
oh great more vicky hey your michael
impression stinks almost as much as your
suit why does everyone keep saying
welcome janet we have a special guest
for you today
hi janet it's me
jason
your boyfriend
i really miss you
i know we were in a fight before but i
hope you've forgiven me because
i love you
girl
not a girl
well janice yeah
how's that make you feel
terrible
here we are
just press that button and it's goodbye
janet
chidi i can see that you're worried and
i just want to assure you i am not human
and i cannot feel pain ah thank you that
helps however i should warn you i am
programmed with a fail-safe measure as
you approach the kill switch i will
begin to beg for my life it's just there
in case of an accidental shutdown but it
will seem very real cool so who's doing
this me or you
uh well i i think i have to um being a
bystander seems worse somehow
okay here we go
no no no chidi please please please
don't hurt me i don't want to die please
again i am not human i can't die
i am simply an anthropomorphized vessel
of knowledge built to make your life
easier your pleading seems
so real oh yes it is a very effective
fail safe
you want a robot killed right you have
to do it yourself
eleanor eleanor no no please wait wait
wait wait eleanor i have kids i have
three
beautiful children tyler emma and little
tiny baby phillip look at tyler tyler
has asthma but he is battling it like a
champ look at him no eleanor look at
them
look at them
oh it's so realistic eleanor again i'm
not human this is a stock photo of the
crowd at the nickelodeon kids choice
award the bad place crew they're all
terrible bullies and they outnumber me
they even have their own bad janet i'll
show you bad janet what
bad janet um where is the nearest cafe
oh um that's a good question it's up
your mom's butt you fat dink
what is even the purpose of a janet who
behaves in such a manner
janet can i have a glass of water please
here you go
oh gosh
you said water yeah i'm so sorry there
you go
ah
if you want them you're gonna have to go
through me that's the idea well it's a
bad idea oh michael
when will you ever screw this let's
get somewhere safe you guys
bad news
i've been going to the gym a lot
12 years of fencing on guard
obviously i'd never do that in the
competition that'd be a three-tenths
deduction
i've never marvelized a janet before
jacksonville style baby 2000 points
thanks jason
cannon
is janet a straight up hottie right now
how are you this close to being dragged
to hell and still partying
and how did you know there were demons
i can't tell you that now
screw it what am i waiting for we could
die in the next 30 seconds
so michael showed me a memory of our
time in the good place
and you and i were like
a thing and
not like a casual hey i found two loose
pills in the bottom of my tote let's pop
them and see what's good kind of thing
we were
in love
and there's a real possibility that i'm
in love with you again
here on this plane of existence uh today
now in canada
during this brawl
with demons
no no
oh cool when i'm even partway through
the door to the afterlife my powers come
back they do
they do thanks for asking
you're coming with me
hi there
[Music]
we did it
well no no no no of course of course
janet did it yes but i had the uh
thank you janet michael good news i was
able to obtain eleanor shellstrop's file
is it actually a cactus i don't
understand i want to see the file for
eleanor shellstrop is that what you have
or do you have a cactus i have the file
you're sure you have the file and not a
cactus that is correct i have eleanor
shellstrop's file i do not have a cactus
excellent please give me the file here
you go
thank you janet you're welcome
i just want to make sure that i have
this right um
giannio is not a taiwanese monk but
rather someone named
jason mendoza a failed dj from
jacksonville florida i wasn't a failed
dj i was
pretty successful and
you two are married hell's yeah homie we
love each other
just like romeo and juliet romeo was the
name of my dog and juliet was the name
of my roomba
she is my everything she makes the bass
drop
in my heart and jason is a person who
was near me
and then he asked me to marry him and
there is nothing in my protocol that
specifically barred that from happening
so i agreed love you too babe
janet
please tell me how this could have
happened unclear as you know each time i
am updated i accrue new knowledge and
abilities my suspicion is that when i
was rebooted i bonded with jason in a
way that i have never bonded with anyone
before i seem to have gained a new
understanding of love i also learned how
to do this
i will speak to you later go to your
void okay
no jenna come back hi there go sure
thing no stop doing that me go goodbye
jenna come back i love you
you